hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of milena masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is to
model the strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're gonna look at how two
friends wanna come in from a middle
class background one coming from
immigrant from Taiwan join forces
believe they could do something great
created a company and eventually sold if
1.65 billion dollars this is a story of
Chad Hurley and Steve Chen from YouTube
and the top three lessons that you can
learn from their success Steve Chen and
Chad Hurley joined forces to build
youtube.com a social video site that
sold to Google for reported 1.65 billion
dollars these two friends met while
working together a PayPal com
they hit it off and would begin spending
a lot of time together discussing their
business ideas however it wasn't until
eBay purchased PayPal for 1.54 billion
that they both would decide to follow
their dreams upon the sale of PayPal the
eBay both China and Hurley would receive
large bonuses they decided to use their
money to create their own venture with
Chinese engineering skills and Hurley's
creativity they thought they had the
right mix to form a company together
they really had no idea about what type
of business to create but felt that
together they could create something
monumental
in January 2005 Hurley and Chen attended
a friend's dinner party in San Francisco
they had taken a few digital videos of
the event and wanted to share them with
each other the next day it could not
find a good way to do it the files were
too big to email and posting them online
would take hours with that Hurley and
China had their first idea for
sustainable business using the money
they had received from the PayPal buyout
Chenin Hurley decided to create YouTube
to make uploading and sharing videos
online as easy as anyone could want
by teaming up and leveraging each
other's strengths and complementing each
other's weaknesses Chen and Hurley were
able to go on to build a company that
itself 1.65 billion dollars to help you
build your company
here are three action items you can
learn from Chen and Hurley action item
number one build an experience many
successful entrepreneurs today are
focusing on not just creating a great
product or service but building an
experience for their customers make it
easy for people to do business with you
and allow them to feel like they are
part of something bigger
they're not just buying from you they're
part of a movement before YouTube came
along online videos were nothing new the
presence on the Internet had been
growing albeit slowly
they were come Watson to upload while
sharing and watches improved even more
difficult few people had the patience or
the desire to wait out the process this
is what Chen and Hurley wanted the
change the experience of people wanted
to share videos with each other they
decided the best way to do this was to
make it easier for people to share what
they wanted to see according to Chen and
Hurley I see her service as one has been
needed for a long time the pieces to
make it all happen just weren't in place
until we came around we needed it to be
a no-brainer
we allowed the community to tell us what
was entertaining them when we started
this company a few years ago we never
expected to be here it's interesting how
the simple idea improving our own video
experience online turned into this
Akshardham number to make the business
unique if you want to send out for your
competitors and compete against the big
brands in your industry you need to find
a way to be unique you have to offer
something different in a creative way
and make potential customers care about
it if you sell the exact same product as
everyone else and provide the exact same
service you're not going to get people
talking and be excited to work with you
Chenin really knew that they had to
create something unique to make people
use their website one of YouTube's major
advantages with that they allowed
everybody to upload videos of themselves
it didn't have to be professionally
edited and they could easily share it
with their friends but made YouTube
unique
was that they made it easier than ever
before to share a quick video of your
mother's birthday or your brother's
wedding you didn't have to be a
technical genius to use their system and
that helped the service go viral
according to Chen and Hurley what our
users want is to watch themselves they
don't want to watch professionally
produced content there are so many
people with cameras that have the
opportunities to create their own
content and so many more people with
editing tools to tell their stories we
feel this is just a tip of the iceberg
we're building a community and we don't
want to bombard people with advertising
action item number three focus on the
customer if you focus on your customer
they'll take care of your business
success get close to them understand
what they really need and get their
feedback on what you can do to be better
businesses that form around customer
problems are more likely to succeed and
are more likely to adopt changes when
the economy dips from day one of YouTube
Hurley and Chen have reaffirmed their
commitment to creating the best possible
service for their customers even when
that came at the expense of the revenues
they are not simply compassion
businessman how to make people happy
instead of making a dollar instead they
see user satisfaction as necessary for
long-term success they believe that
every successful business must start and
listen to their customers and focus on
the customers wants according to Chen
and Hurley if we wanted to we could have
instantly turned this into a ten million
dollar in revenue business per month are
running pre-rolls on the videos but at
that same time we're going to make sure
that whatever revenue model we've built
is going to be something that's accepted
by the users we're not in a hurry we're
interested in building our community
we're trying to improve discovery we're
trying to improve the experience for
people on our site
so remember build an experience make the
company unique and focus on the customer
to finish up this video I wanted to
share one of my favorite true stories
about the YouTube guys and some of their
best quotes after the dinner party that
gave Chen and Hurley the business idea
for YouTube they wanted a simple way to
share their videos of the night so they
immediately went to work on creating the
answer they witnessed a massive growth
of sites such as MySpace I wondered how
they could leverage that growth to their
advantage instead of building their own
social networking site Hurley and Chyna
wanted to take advantage of those that
were already out there to that end they
made it easy for members of those sites
to embed YouTube videos on their pages
they work with those companies that were
already out there instead of trying to
go against them by following this
strategy Chenin Hurley found it easier
to build upon their idea and her company
began to take off
thank you for joining me for another
edition of all in the masters if you
like the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear what you have to think
about the video if you liked it or if
you didn't like it leave a comment
underneath the video and we'll see you
on the next episode
you